[Musique]
on
bonjour à tous est ravie de vous
retrouver pour les matins du sénat on
l'a vu encore pendant le confinement
alors que les relations sociales ont pu
se maintenir grâce au digital
et bien certains en étaient exclues
l'accès au numérique a une dimension
cruciale aujourd'hui dans notre société
alors comment faciliter ces usages
formés et d une mission d'information
sur la lutte contre l'illettrisme a été
créé au sénat à l'initiative du groupe
rdse et aujourd'hui nous vous proposons
de suivre la table ronde qui était
organisée hier avec des opérateurs et
sociétés du numérique mort cet
après-midi sera un bref car notre
édition est ce que d'être très dense que
d'autres même très longue
je vous remercie d'avoir accepté votre
audition en visioconférence ainsi
organiser en raison des circonstances
solitaire exceptionnelle que nous
connaissons nous avons souhaité cet
après-midi entendre les principaux
opérateurs et acteurs privés du
numérique
car la formation des 13 millions de
français qui sont exclus du numérique
ont raison d'un déficit de compétences
ne relève pas uniquement de la
responsabilité de l'état très un
simulateur
d'ailleurs dès les collectivités
territoriales les mieux armés pour les
détecter cette formation incombe
également à tous les acteurs de réseaux
comme aux plateformes c'est en coalisant
leurs forces que public privé et public
que publics et privés pardon pourront
faire reculer l'illettrisme numérique
vous êtes conscient puisque vous avez
chacun dans votre domaine qui des
initiatives pour lutter contre
l'exclusion numérique et l'électronique
je vous invite à la présenter brièvement
on est précis en précisant les
initiatives prises le cas échéant
pendant la période de compliments liés à
l'épidémie
le kop 19 des communes 19 et à nous
donner votre évaluation de la pertinence
de la stratégie nas
le numérique inclusif nous faisons part
le cas échéant de vos propositions
d'amélioration la fondation aujourd'hui
elle a soutenu plus de 300 projets tous
axés sur les thèmes contre la venue mais
belle facture numérique
c'est un des livres à la fois un appui
financier matériel mais aussi parfois un
soutien logistique et l'organisation de
rencontres avec les collaborateurs du
pignada pour échanger sur les parcours
et les formations qui sont accessibles
la fondation
aujourd'hui elle elle est active autour
de cinq thèmes principaux le premier
c'est accompagner l'insertion sociale
grâce au numérique qu'on a un impact un
partenariat avec une association qui est
spécialisée en spécialisé là dedans qui
avait déjà été évoquée par google france
qui s'appelle connexions je passe très
vite là dessus on a aussi une politique
interne de formation des collaborateurs
qui est assez poussé le groupe free
c'est un important créateur d'emplois on
a créé de 5000 emplois sur les six
dernières années en moyenne un tiers de
nos recrutements aux moins de 25 ans 20%
n'ont pas de diplôme donc il ya investi
beaucoup sur la formation à l'embauché
et la formation tout au long du parcours
professionnel de nos collaborateurs
c'est pour ça qu'on a attaché à créer
beaucoup de rencontres avec les
associations que l'on soutient par
ailleurs vous pouvoir échanger sur ses
retours d'expérience le deuxième axe de
la fondation c'est l'éducation aux bons
usages du numérique
comment utiliser les ressources
numériques protéger ses données
apprendre à utiliser les ressources
informatiques
on a un partenariat qui est structurelle
avec une association qui s'appelle n'a
pas venir qui est également soutenue par
les programmes d'investissements
d'avenir et par l'état et qu'une
dispense des formations aux bons usages
du numérique
et puis par ailleurs pour soutenir les
plus petites structures dans les
territoires on a lancé il ya quelques
années un appel à projet qui s'appelle
internet témoin qui a permis de
de diffuser et pratique responsable
d'internet travers de cette petite
association dans différents territoires
la 3 le troisième axe c'est tout alors
anthony que l'on gagne en parler c'est
équipé et donner du matériel pour les
gens qui manquent d'équipements pour
accéder au numérique on a un partenariat
avec les ateliers du bocage qui récupère
pour reconditionner et redistribuer ou à
défaut quand ce n'est pas le cas aux
cycles et des terminaux donc ils sont
des téléphones ou des ordinateurs par
exemple depuis le début de l'année 2020
free a fait don de 3000 téléphone qui
ont ainsi acquis vont pouvoir ainsi être
conditionnés et redistribuer le
quatrième axe et l'accompagnement des
territoires dans la transition numérique
on a apporté mon avis différents appels
à projets sur cette thématique là par
exemple pour la ville de tourcoing on a
aidé à mettre en place un programme
d'expérimentation togola est
inintelligente qui a été conçu et
élaboré avec les habitants de la ville
à la réunion on a soutenu des
associations qui vont créer des
plateformes de rencontres pour les
acteurs d'une même commune entre
collectivités associations entreprises
locales et citoyens ou encore on a un
partenariat qui associe renouvelé chaque
année avec la métropole john yoo autour
d'un projet soutenu également par les
agences numériques à la banque des
territoires qui s'appelle roger super
demain et qui organise un événement
annuel autour des questions d'éducation
autour du miel
et puis enfin pour conclure les derniers
axes d'action c'est l'inclusion des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
pour lesquels des outils numériques va
apporter certaines réponses et tu
peuvent les accompagner et les aider à
s'insérer dans la société
donc pour ça on a plusieurs partenariats
avec des associations et on vient de
clôturer un dernier appel à projets sur
cette thématique et appels à projets qui
a eu beaucoup de succès puisqu'on a eu
presque pas loin de 100 demandes de
dossiers et d'autres associations
différentes et donc on va pouvoir
accompagner une partie d'entre elles
avec pour leur permettre de développer
des innovations technologiques qui va
accompagner les personnes ont
difficilement visuelle auditive où il ya
encore certains projets qui vont
permettre d'accompagner les personnes en
situation de déficience intellectuelle
voilà je pense que j'ai rempli mon temps
et je me tiens à votre disposition
répondre aux questions notamment sur les
engagements pendant la crise
il ya eu beaucoup de choses de faites
peut-être juste mentionné le soutien qui
a été apporté à l'éducation nationale
vient notre signal du toubib qui pour
permettre à tous les atouts les
professeurs de disposer de solution de
visio et de et de serveurs adapté pour
le pad de confinement il ya eu une
grande mise à disposition de la part de
ces solutions pour permettre d'absorber
la la charge de trafic lié à l'éducation
à disposition merci nous continuons avec
cette fois ci le microsoft france
également une intervention à deux voix
avec celle de laurence larsson qui est
directrice des opérations et de spector
de rivoire qui est directeur des
affaires institutionnelles
madame la faune s'il voulait bien il y
avait la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs et mesdames les
sénateurs tout d'abord merci à vous de
nous offrir cette opportunité cette
occasion de contribuer aux réflexions de
la mission d'information relative à la
lutte contre l'électronique mme et pour
l'inclusion numérique
alors je crois que la crise sanitaire
économique que nous vivons actuellement
a mis en lumière la nécessité
d'accentuer la transformation des
entreprises bien sûr des organisations
publiques
elle a aussi montré un haut niveau
d'électro nisme qui touche les
populations les plus fragiles le site et
les personnes peu diplômées les ménages
aux revenus modestes et également les
seniors en tant qu'entreprise engagé
dans ce combat nous pensons vraiment
chez microsoft que la quatrième
révolution industrielle et bien elle ne
doit pas réservé les opportunités
d'emploi à une élite universitaire et
quand on parle d'inclusion numérique et
bien finalement pour nous
il ya deux sujets importants d'une part
s'assurer que toute personne possède
véritablement les outils bien sûr et les
connaissances numériques nécessaires
pour s'intégrer à notre société et
d'autre part également qu'il est
absolument indispensable de diffuser et
de démocratiser la formation au
numérique et à l'intelligence
artificielle en particulier qui est
véritablement aujourd'hui au coeur de
cette révolution numérique et des
opportunités d'emploi dans les années à
venir alors engagés dans ces combats
contre l'électro nisme nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui vous présenter trois grandes
actions en fait que nous avons menées
sur ce front d'une part les écoles
intelligence artificielle
d'autre part nos initiatives en matière
d'accessibilité et puis enfin je voulais
évoquer la coalition gardant le lien que
nous avons mis en place pour répondre
aux enjeux et aux besoins dans le cadre
de la crise née au kobe 19
alors peut-être pour commencer sur les
écoles intelligence artificielle
quelques chiffres que je souhaitais
partager avec vous qui met finalement et
bien en lumière un peu le paysage dans
lequel s'inscrivent ces actions rappeler
simplement que les professions liées à
l'intelligence artificielle elles ont
connu un développement extrêmement
rapide ces dernières années avec une
multiplication par 16 du nombre de
postes de professionnels dans l'ia est
que le champ des opportunités quand on
regarde les perspectives d'emploi en
france autour de l'ia est en champ
extrêmement large et très prometteur par
contre le niveau d'éducation des
professionnels aujourd'hui dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
des particulièrement élevé en france
avec 67% d'entre eux qui ont un niveau
de master et -2 5% qui ont un diplôme
sanctionnant deux ans d'études ou bien
issus de l'enseignement secondaire et là
je crois qu'il ya une véritable
faiblesse de notre modèle français
puisque nous sommes l'un des pays au
niveau de l' ocde avec cette disparité
la plus importante entre de très haut
niveau de formation qui accèdent à ces
métiers dans le domaine de l'uniat et
d'autres niveaux de formation moins
qualifiés on est aussi je souhaiterais
le souvenir dans une très loin de la
parité notamment de genre puisque
seulement 19 % de femmes parmi les
professionnels
opère dans le domaine de l'intelligence
artificielle en france alors pour
revenir à cette initiative les écoles
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
projet que nous avons menée en
partenariat avec simplon simplement que
nous soutenons depuis 2010 nous avons
travaillé sur des projets pilotes dans
le domaine notamment du développement
des métiers du web et d'accessibilité à
des profils sans diplôme dans ce cadre
là et en 2018 et bien nous avons
souhaité ouvrir cette école intelligence
artificielle on a une première promotion
sur notre campus en partenariat avec
simplon est depuis eh bien cette école a
grandi nous avons aujourd'hui avec notre
écosystème de partenaires d'orange que
je salue également aujourd'hui capgemini
et cetera est simple on est bien nous
avons développé un réseau de 14 écoles
qui sont dédiés à la formation en
intelligence artificielle sur l'ensemble
du territoire français
paris nantes castelnau biarritz lyon
bordeaux etc mais particularité elles
sont les suivantes les apprenants qui
sont environ 24 par promotion ont entre
19 et 49 ans ils sont en reconversion
professionnelle éloignés de l'emploi ou
décrocheurs scolaires ils vont
bénéficier d'une formation intensive de
sept mois et ensuite ils sont accueillis
pendant 12 mois en alternance au sein
des entreprises partenaires de microsoft
et l'objectif est bien de ces écoles il
est véritablement de mettre le numérique
au service de l'intérêt général et à la
portée de tous pour favoriser
l'inclusion et favoriser l'accès à ces
nouveaux métiers
la sélection des élèves elle vise à
répondre à cet objectif 80 % des
étudiants sont des demandeurs d'emploi
61 % en août un niveau équivalent ou
inférieur au bac
35% des apprenants sont des femmes et
ainsi les apprenants de la formation et
bien ils ont été recrutés en partenariat
avec simplon avec pôle emploi et la
grande école du numérique sur leurs
compétences techniques bien sûr c'est
maîtrise de certains langages de
programmation est d'ailleurs simple on
peut offrir un complément pour les
personnes qui en ont besoin
des connaissances en mathématiques est
relativement rudimentaire et surtout une
très grande motivation à s'engager dans
ce type de formation elle n'impose aucun
prérequis diplôme et elle cible les
demandeurs d'emploi comme je l'évoquais
on a également dans le cas de ce
programme d'éco ligne a monté deux
promotions spécifiques une promotion
ambitions féminine où nous avions 80
pour
femmes je rappelle le sujet absolument
important d'amener plus de femmes dans
les métiers liés au numérique et à
l'intelligence artificielle en
particulier et puis une autre promotion
que nous appelons promotion intelligence
atypique de 36 apprenants qui est en
cours actuellement et pour laquelle et
bien nous avons 12 profil asker et au
potentiel
voilà un exemple d'initiative qui de
notre point de vue contribuer à
véritablement et bien l'unité les enjeux
de fracture numérique et contribue à
l'inclusion de tous dans l'accès à ces
nouveaux métiers
le deuxième engagement je voulais
évoquer les en matière d'accessibilité
cela a déjà été évoqué par un certain
nombre de mes confrères en france pour
rappeler quelques chiffres le plus de
deux millions de citoyens sont en
situation de handicap ou partant de
secondes style nous avons intégré dans
nos produits dans nos services d'accor
fils 365 des fonctionnalités qui
permettent véritablement à des personnes
en situation de handicap et bien de
travailler efficacement pour tout
appareil
rappelons que le handicap n'est pas
toujours un handicap permanent ce peut
être un handicap passagers et qui peut
créer une véritable situation
d'exclusion par rapport au numérique on
peut citer par exemple un quelques
fonctionnalités comme des capacités
visuelles auditives vocal de mobilité
d'apprentissage qui sont intégrés dans
nos outils qui vont permettre est bien
de créer communiquer collaborer sur des
contenus en toute facilité
on a aussi développé un certain nombre
d'initiatives complémentaires pour
améliorer l'accessibilité numérique en
faveur de personnes notamment
malvoyantes on a ainsi lancé une
application qui s'appelle singh et gagne
nous pourrons vous donner le lien dans
le dans le chatt également qui est
disponible en français et qui est
véritablement destiné à un public
présentant des déficiences visuelles
elle permet en fait au travers de la
caméra d'un téléphone de lire un texte
de reconnaître des personnes des images
des objets et appréhender
l'environnement
bien sûr elle s'appuie sur
l'intelligence artificielle et elle va
décrire à l'oral finalement ces
situations pour permettre à dessouder
personnes souffrant de déficience
visuelle et bien de mieux appréhender
leur environnement autre exemple nous
avons monté en partenariat avec corey
point fr en fait une formation en ligne
gratuite
bhl à tous pour que chacun puisse
comprendre les enjeux de l'accessibilité
et connaître les solutions numériques
qui existent tels que encore une fois
l'utilisation par exemple de lecteurs
immersif où le système de traduction
instantanée ou de victimes locales
dernière initiative que je souhaitais
évoquer gardant le lien que nous avons
mis en place dans le cadre de la crise
sanitaire que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
cette crise elle a mis en exergue comme
je l'évoquais l'illettrisme mais pardon
électro nismo notamment chez les seniors
qui ont été finalement eh bien on l'a vu
les premiers touchés par un isolement
important en cette période de
confinement est donc dans ce cadre là eh
bien nous avons participé à l'initiative
gardons le lien monté avec la fondation
simplon et un grand nombre d'autres
acteurs sur le marché français fnac
crédit agricole axa darty alstom orange
pour en nommer quelques uns pour fournir
et bien des ordinateurs ou des tablettes
aux ehpad et aux hôpitaux
l'objectif de ce projet il était simple
c'était vraiment de s'assurer bien la
connexion entre les malades atteints du
coc vie de 19 et leurs proches et tout
particulièrement est bien de rompre
l'isolément de ces malades et apaiser
l'angoissé famille qui n'était plus là
pas citer d'avoir un contact direct
l'utilisation en ehpad a connu un fort
succès également pour permettre encore
une fois à 2 des seniors totalement
isolé de garder le lien avec leur s avec
leur famille ou avec les aidants
le collectif a travaillé en coordination
avec des collectivités territoriales
pour distribuer 20 mille tablettes qui
ont permis à 150000 personnes résidant
dans la france entière et bien de garder
ce contact est créé seulement voilà je
pense que c'est un exemple d'initiative
qu'il faut regarder à porter dans la
durée et au delà de la crise actuelle il
est important de mener une réflexion me
semble-t-il sur des initiatives
similaires qui vise à équiper formé
notamment les seniors isolés et rendre
ainsi leur isolement numérique dans la
durée voilà je vous remercie j'en reste
là pour les quelques exemples de nos de
nos contributions et réflexions pour
aider sur ces thématiques de l'inclusion
numérique et de l'électronique en france
etc
chez les torchons clim sachant que même
la fonte à vient d'entamer votre temps
de parole en étant papa hector je
voudrais
vous entendez mais nous ne nous
entendons pas passer non qu'on passe en
ouvrant votre micro
bon alors je propose enfants et propose
qu'on passe à alain lanty
vous êtes là monsieur non avec orange
également une intervention à deux voix
celle de madame françoise consent qui
était général délégué général de la
fondation orange directrice du mécénat
du mécénat et solidarité chalvidant qui
disent des relations institutionnelles
en n'imposant vous avez la parole je
vais être tué je vais commencer très
succinctement parce que finalement je
crois qu on se rejoint un peu tous sur
les constats on peut faire sur le ce
besoin de l'égalité numérique et
d'inclusion peut-être juste vous
rappeler en préambule que la fondation
orange dette de 87 et ses prolongements
très naturelle de la mission de
l'entreprise qu'elle permettre à tous de
mieux communiquer ce titre orange pilote
depuis de nombreuses années différents
programmes et d'intrusion aussi bien en
france qu'en europe en points ou en
afrique moyen-orient où orange est
présent dans 26 pays
et évidemment on va se concentrer
aujourd'hui sur le sur la france mais
c'est pour vous montrer qu'à la fois
avec la fondation nos différents
services orange france orange espagne
pologne
on propose des offres adaptées au public
et aussi grâce à nos directions
diversité et l'inclusion puisque orange
a cette force d'avoir un maillage local
est tendu et donc on a des
correspondants rse et fondations au
local et une autre particularité notre
conception de notre travail pour réduire
cette inégalité numérique
c'est aussi une méthode de travail avec
des dialogues parties prenantes et on
retrouve ce que ce que bouygues telecom
ou ce que free a pu dire en introduction
c'est que dans ces dialogues on a pu se
rendre compte que parfois ces jeunes qui
sont très très à l'aise avec les réseaux
sociaux pour leur propre développement
personnel finalement ne savent pas se
servir mais que c'est attendu pour eux
pour trouver un emploi ont fait des
démarches en ligne autour des impôts
rechercher de l'information et c'est là
où on voit que finalement l'équipement
ne fait pas tout et que l'usagé
l'accompagnement est fondamentale et ses
raisons notamment qu'orange a choisi de
faire de l'égalité numérique une de ses
ambitions de nouveau plan stratégique
qui démarre là en 2020 jusqu'en 2025
il ya deux pieds à ceux à ce plan
stratégique c'est une lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et des sujets
dans les romans et puis le deuxième qui
est fondamental qu'il fait l'objet
aujourd'hui cette table ronde c'est
l'égalité numérique
c'est pourquoi je suis venu avec
françoise cossou qui va vous présenter
en fait nous nous engagions de mala très
concrète et spécifique en france
et puis en ce compris évidemment pendant
la crise le cette question a été
particulièrement forte comme vous l'avez
tout seul souligne c'est le cochonnet
bon jour à tout
merci à monsieur le président bonjour à
social faussement son président sur un
porteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
donc je vais pas leur dire en clair là
insister sur les enjeux des inclusions
numérique c'est vraiment au coeur des
préoccupations du groupe on sait que l
être hors du numérique c'est le priver
d'un puissant moteur et développement
individuel et collectif soucier prix
mais dans l'accès à l'éducation à la
formation à l'emploi à la santé au lien
social au service public et privé aux
services financiers la mobilité et même
à l'exercice de la démocratie
alors on va aussi de la
dématérialisation des principales
démarches auprès des services publics
alors que près de 13 millions de
français sont-ils électronique est en
incapacité d'utiliser numérique dans
leur lit cours en ce bas montre l'effort
qu'il y à faire si on ne veut pas que le
numérique soit un accélérateur de ses
inégalités
donc le groupe orange a fait le choix de
s'engager depuis longtemps chaque entité
participent question qu'on contribue à
lui et moi je vous présente alors que ce
qu'on fait à la fondation qui existe
depuis 30 ans car la digue mais où
depuis 2014
nous accompagnons des programmes pour
faire du numérique un facteur d'égalité
des chances pour tous
nous avons développé des programmes
d'éducation numérique avec des parcours
de formation pour des publics éloignés
le numérique et plus particulièrement
pour les jeunes et les femmes sans
diplôme sans formation souvent dans les
situations précarité en 2014 donc via
des appels à projets les associations
financièrement mais aussi avec un
accompagnement humain et c'est très
important très important nous avons des
médiateurs numérique sur la formation
des bénéficiaires
nous assurons aussi la mise à
disposition de contenus dans ces lieux
des lieux qui sont désavoués d'insertion
numérique des lyonnais stations
professionnelles mais aussi on le voit
tous les jours des lieux d'insertion
sociale alors dans ces lieux dans ses
programmes structurants nous allons des
maisons digital à destination des femmes
dans lesquelles nous allons proposer des
formations aux digital commencerez une
identité numérique comment se crée
comment suivre les devoirs des enfants
comment faire inscrire il vous
connaissez tout ça donc on a 300 grammes
et en digital dans 24 pays
on en a semblé en france ensuite nous
avons des femmes solidaires pour les
jeunes 18-25 ans à peu près 129 fab lab
dans 19 pays dont 64 aujourd'hui en
france des ateliers numériques aussi en
france 46 me l'atelier depuis 2014 qui
sont les missions locales
vraiment ancré dans les territoires ont
permis de former 50 mille jeunes cette
année
et puis des programmes avec les missions
locales encore des programmes
d'insertion pour les jeunes 149 projet
est soutenu cette année
et puis pour les territoires ruraux
qu'on ne les ont pas nous avons été
induits en détient dieu solidaire qui
sont des créations de lui avec les
collectivités locales et les mairies des
vieux équipés avec des médiateurs
numérique aujourd'hui nous en avons 23
en france dans les territoires très
éloignés
alors que tous ses programmes en france
nous avons formé à boca 75000 personnes
c'est déjà important mais on voit bien
qu'il ya un énorme besoin
et puis dans ces lieux pour former ces
personnes on l'a aussi ouvert une
bibliothèque numérique avec des
confrères cessible
maintenant là pour vous parler d'un cas
unique par exemple pendant cette période
de confinement nous avons participé à la
lah à la traduction de remettre les cons
alors bien sûr beaucoup de programmes
sur l'inclusion numérique mais aussi des
programmes où le numérique nous servent
alors l'épreuve d'accès à la culture
pour tous avec la façon des mous qui
sont des des cours en ligne des projets
avec des musées des institutions de six
très juste notre partenariat avec les
micros folie de la vilaine dans les
quartiers défavorisés
des actions aussi autour de la lecture
et de l'accès au monde de la littérature
et les soutiens aux actions pédagogiques
qui ont des festivals littéraires aussi
dans la musique avec les diffusant des
opéras bien sûr pour les personnes qui
n'ont pas la possibilité financière ou
matérielle d'y aller dans la santé nous
sommes aussi très présent pour les
clients de tous notamment pour les
personnes avec autisme
on soutient des projets depuis on attend
près trente ans beaucoup de projets
numériques des projets d'expérimentation
mais aussi des projets autour de la
recherche des projets aussi pour de
l'habitat partagé aujourd'hui on a
accompagné plus de 4200 personnes avec
autisme dans nos projets on voit son
description rapide de tous les projets
que nous soutenons en france je décrirai
pas les problèmes les projets qu'on se
retient dans les zones middle east
africa et en europe mais qui tourne
aussi beaucoup autour du numérique avec
les écoles
ils n'ont plus de 1000 écoles en afrique
des programmes en pologne versé au
numérique pour les plus éloignés ou en
roumanie vont le choix j'ai la réussite
aujourd'hui il faudrait aussi insisté
sur le sur la dynamique aussi
d'engagement solidaire des salariés aux
anges
aujourd'hui nous avons un programme de
mécénat de compétences de 500 salariés
qui sont dans des associations financées
non par l'europe au rhône et nous en
avons deux formes qui organise des
formations des ateliers numériques les
plus défavorisés dans les structures
josé parlé précédemment donc les maisons
digital les fables airs solidaires et
les programmes d'insertion pour les
jeunes non c'est vraiment sans vraiment
une force considérable qui accompagnent
au quotidien les bénéficiaires et les
actions des associations ce qui nous
permet d'avoir vraiment une connaissance
de ces associations le connaître nos
bénéficiaires
et puis d'avoir un ancrage dans tous les
territoires en france alors chez orange
moi je vous ai parlé de la formation
parce que c'est ce que je connais le
mieux bien évidemment mais chaque entité
contribuer car a dit notamment bien sûr
en facilitant la série d activités en
préparant les réseaux de demain on entre
maintenant et en réparant les réseaux
surtout nos jours ainsi mais aussi en
proposant des offres inclusive dans
chaque pays dans lequel nous sommes
présents dans les 26 pays et en
apportant une attention toute
particulière à tous nos publics les plus
fragiles alors en france on a bien sûr
un dispositif d'offre social avec la
téléphonie et l'internet social
téléphonique avec votre offre coup pouf
l'époque ce qui est des coûts lancé en
juillet 2019 je range est le seul à le
faire
aujourd'hui on à 4500 bénéficiaires des
foyers à faibles revenus qui sont pas ou
très mal équipés ont connexion internet
à domicile
il ya aussi le fond soleil est une
solidarité logement qui nous permet aux
prescriptions d'un travailleur social
d'échelonner ou d'effacer à saleux
facture est huit heures des clients en
grande difficulté on mène aussi les
actions dans nos boutiques donc tout néo
nos boutiques en france des actions
d'accompagnement à la parentalité à la
formation les parents et des enfants
dans des ateliers numériques par des
coachs numériques qui sont des
mais aussi par des ateliers numériques
pour faciliter la maîtrise des outils
numériques pour essayant même pas que
pour les seniors de population et
notamment de nos clients qui via ses
ateliers peuvent être sensibilisés et
utiliser les outils numériques
je vais pas vous en parler de tout mais
partenariat que nous allons est simple
on avec microsoft en a déjà parlé mais
nous sommes aussi très présent sur tous
ces projets collaboratifs qu'on aime
bien donner un peu en expérimentation
alors c'est donc bien tout le groupe qui
s'engage cet engagement à former et
accompagner les personnes numérique il a
été la figure le disais dans notre plan
stratégique engagement 5 présenté par
stéphane richard en début d'année on
s'est d'ailleurs engagé à ouvrir d'ici
2025 en orange jetta center dans toutes
nos divisions opérationnelles en france
et dans le pays alors c'est orange
digital santos ce sont des lieux sains
qui avec une approche assez simple et
inclusive pour encourager la formation
avec des écoles du code mais aussi
l'inclusion avec la fable à sondernach
accords en gîte à senteur et puis
l'innovation avec un accompagnement des
start up et un soutien aux titres
numériques locales peuvent ainsi rappelé
si vous permettez que dans le cadre de
la loi impact assez récente le groupe a
inscrit dans ses statuts sa volonté
d'exemplarité social en formalisant sa
raison d'être
alors orange est le partenaire de
confiance qui offre à chacune et à
chacun les clés d'un monde numérique
responsable
cette raison d'être a été validée en
assemblée générale la semaine dernière
avec la mission qui en découlent de
garantir que dans tous nos champs
d'activité le numérique soit pensée mis
à disposition est utilisé de façon plus
humaine plus inclusive et plus durable
juste pour conclure un petit zoom sur
notre mobilisation solidaire pendant
cette crise sanitaire
on a vu l'importance de maîtriser les
outils numériques et le risque à la
santé
la fracture numérique on vient de toutes
nos formations et nos filiales c'est une
exceptionnelle de 8 millions d'euros qui
a été attribué sur tous nos pays j'ai
fait un petit zoom sur la france avec
bien sûr des dons à la fondation de
france
à l'ap-hp à la croix rouge
en soutien aux soignants au monde
médical et aux patients la recherche
mais aussi des soutiens avec l'envoi de
plus de 1000 tablettes de type de
connexion dans les structures
hospitalières dans les ehpad dans nos
associations partenaires dans l'escaut
d'accueil et des solutions bien sûr pour
maintenir le lien de 1 mde des patients
et les familles et puis les solutions et
des conflits aussi mises à disposition
gratuitement pour apprendre et continuer
à ce que le style et à distance et puis
ils ont parlé de nous laisser naître en
compte de compétentes cependant sa crise
nos deux sens à d'ailleurs laissé notre
compétence ont rejoint la mobilisation
des médiateurs numérique bénévoles sur
la plateforme lancée par le secrétariat
d'état au numérique solidarité numérique
afin d'aider par téléphone ou en ligne
les personnes les plus isolées voile
alors on tour opérateur orange a
également accompagner ses clients en
france
en offrant 10 gigas l'internet mobile
supplémentaire les chaînes de tv en
chair on a doublé avec les autres
opérateurs a le temps où charles
accessibilité téléphonique pour l'état
[Musique]
physique
voilà donc nous avons été très engagé
pendant toute cette crise
et puis on voit aussi qu'aujourd'hui on
discute avec tous nos partenaires et des
associations et nos programmes parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de nos bénéficiaires
en difficulté qui n'ont pas été ce sont
un peu perdus que l'on a un peu perdu
par manque d'équipement donc il va
falloir faire en accompagnement ce
soutien de l'équipement mais ne pas être
un équipementier solidaire en est ainsi
présent via no no no no médiateur et nos
appels à projets sont comme des
solutions vous dire que nous sommes très
engagés dans ce domaine nous portons une
certaine responsabilité nous sommes pas
les seules discussions parce que il
convient clé que les gouvernements les
organismes internationaux les bailleurs
de fonds les associations et tous les
acteurs du numérique
donc il existe de cet enjeu pour faire
d'internet et du numérique une chance
pour tous voilà merci beaucoup de votre
attention
merci à vous et enfin nous terminons
cette première partie avec la fondation
sfr qui est également avec un binôme
composé de madame julie le sort qui est
délégué général à la fondation sfr et de
madame claire percée qui directrice des
relations aux institutionnels
je laisse la parole à celle qui voudra
bien apprendre
en premier lieu on a percé oui je vais
je vais commenter merci monsieur le
président bonjour à toutes et à tous
donc avec julie le serbe qui est délégué
général de la fondation avec très
heureuse de participer à cette table
ronde sur l'inclusion numérique parce
que c'est un sujet qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur chez sfr
un sujet sur lequel nous travaillons
depuis bientôt dix ans avec notre
partenaire emmaüs connect sfr a fait un
choix pionniers à une époque où
l'inclusion numérique n'étaient pas
encore identifiées comme une urgence
sociale
alors cette urgence sociale elle est
apparue avec les années elle est apparue
de manière flagrante avec la
dématérialisation des services publics
puis elle est devenue criante ces
dernières semaines avec le co vide et le
confinement que nous avons vécu pourquoi
ce combat est bien parce que il
constitue tout simplement le corollaire
des déploiements des réseaux fixes et
mobiles que nous réalisons à travers le
pays en tant qu'opérateur télécom
déployer des réseaux c'est fondamental
évidemment pour l'inclusion numérique
mais permettre aux personnes de savoir
s'en servir c'est tout aussi essentiels
comme je le disais ce défi de
l'inclusion numérique sfr en a fait une
priorité de tout dix ans en participant
à la création d'emmaüs connect sommes le
partenaire fondateur d'emmaüs connect
qui est aujourd'hui l'association de
référence en matière d'électronique mhz
et d'un pigeon numérique et quoi savoir
ce sont plus de 200 collaborateurs de
sfr qui n'ont pas la naissance de cette
association et vous dire si ce projet
nous tenait à coeur au sein de
l'entreprise pour être très concret l
affaire en partenariat avec emmaüs
connect agi autour de trois grandes
priorités équipe est connecté et former
un accompagnement à 360 degrés en dix
ans nous avons ouvert très espace de
celui là
des numériques grandes villes de france
on continue on continue à en ouvrir un
autre qui sont un projet au sein des
centres on trouve deux choses la
première c'est du matériel à tarif
solidaire c'est à dire des smartphones
des cartes sim des cartes prépayées qui
sont donnés par sfr pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée sfr chaque année plus de 4
millions d'euros de dons en nature à
emmaüs connaît
la deuxième chose c'est de la formation
comptable évidemment et je pense qu'on y
reviendra au delà de ces espaces de
solidarité du développement avec emmaüs
connect et avec pôle emploi depuis 2018
et parcours d'accompagnement aux
compétences numériques de base pour les
demandeurs d'emploi ce sont des
formations de 32 heures qui permettent
d'accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi
vers une autonomie numérique durable
l'objectif c'est berlin qui soit capable
de chercher seul en emploi via internet
puisque l'on sait aujourd'hui 90 % des
emplois se trouvent par internet ne sait
pas s'en servir
c'est pas compliqué ça leur permet aussi
de faire seuls leurs démarches pour près
de pôle emploi où par exemple le lac
donc ça c'est ses neuf et noir où on va
dire tout ce qu'on met en oeuvre pour
accompagner les individus les personnes
en parallèle de cet accompagnement des
personnes et fr et sa fondation
accompagne également les territoires ou
réduire la fracture numérique dans le
cadre de nos réponses aux appels
d'offres pour les délégations de service
public ou pour les appels à
manifestation d'engagements nouveaux
locaux le déploiement de la fibre à
travers le territoire
sfr accompagne les départements dans la
mise en oeuvre de leur stratégie
l'inclusion numérique
cet accompagnement il se concrétise de
deux manières la première est grâce à un
fonds se font un pont inclus dans la
délégation de service public un fonds
qui est dédié à l'inclusion numérique et
qui permet de mettre en place des
actions concrètes en faveur de
l'inclusion numérique
je vous prends un exemple très concret
qui est assez raide sans mais ce fonds a
permis de financer les passes numérique
qui ont été lancées avec thé brick haut
avec le département des pyrénées
atlantiques et avec la fondation sfr en
février dernier ce sont des pas qui sont
conçus sur le modèle des tic et les
tickets restaurant et qui vont permettre
d'accéder à des services
d'accompagnement au numérique
dans des lieux référencés ensuite et là
je vais laisser la parole à juillet le
sort qui est délégué général de la
fondation sfr est de faire accompagner
territoires dans leur stratégie
l'inclusion numérique grâce à son
partenariat avec mitac caire jusqu'à la
parole
vous ne le serez léger vous nous
entendez mais montrez votre micro jeux
simulés parce que je pense que n'est pas
nouvelle
moi sinon je fais je vais poursuivre je
vous propose de poursuivre ben on n'a
pas d'autre choix
voilà mais continuez sur le sur we take
care donc week-end entendez à oui ça y
est quand on july pardon excusez moi ça
a mis du temps pourtant s'était pourtant
je n'étais pas au mieux donc je du coup
je vais reprendre
excusez-moi interruption oui nos
critères qui l a poussé à toute heure
des mes collègues c'est le même
fondateur on en a parlé à leur rigueur a
été le coup rapporteur du rapport sur la
stratégie nationale pour un numérique
inclusif tennis vraiment que c'est
l'acteur de référence dans le domaine à
travers l'autre partenariat avec les
protecteurs il ya on a amené on a
déployé deux places d'apprentissage en
ligne pour été créé pour faciliter un
accompagnement d'avoir quitté l'homme
qui pour ce qui permet de faciliter
l'accès des jeunes à l'emploi avec
notamment un générateur de série 2 cv
personnalisé et ensuite les banques
liszt et ainsi de ressources
pédagogiques pour accompagner le grand
public et les perles que le numérique
avec notamment existence avant des
formations sur les services essentiels
ans j'ai déjà le site et des formations
de compétences numériques
ainsi les outils pour les aidants et ses
pairs et du secteur accompagne depuis
maintenant trois ans déjà comme vie
comme pôle emploi la caf des
collectivités les départements du
morbihan de campagne est déterrée
l'atlantique ou encore léo date sur
lequel on travaille on travaille en ce
moment ainsi que des acteurs d'insertion
comme les centres sociaux et l'édition
mission locale l'objectif avec entre
l'objectif de ce partenariat entre vitae
caire et sfr et d'apporter en fait à ces
territoires tenu des besoins et des
ressources de l'existant afin de mettre
en place une véritable stratégie
baptisée numériques adaptés et là ça
peut prendre que la de prendre
différentes formes comme la curation
d'un d'un réseau départemental de
l'onirique est fondamental la création
de parcours d'accompagnement pour
permettre d'atteindre l'autonomie
numérique et enfin baladi valises à
l'exposition de cette fameuse de
plateformes les bons flics aux acteurs
sociaux pour les permettre de de pouvoir
aux lieux et des citoyens dans leur dans
leur apprentissage des voix là et enfin
le avec huit acteurs ou mail en
partenariat également avec et l'alcool
est évidemment le dépouillement de
l'offre d'acs solidaire en partenariat
avec les verts puisque c'est elle au
delà de d'avoir cet accompagnement
numérique
il ya un véritable besoin de connexion
d'équipements et de collection voilà
donc les éléments une véritablement une
offre 362 je vais faire reprendre sur la
partie fois la partie cosider toutes les
actions que nous avons menées sur la
plus numérique pendant quatorze du
continent voilà donc du jeu reprend la
parole effectivement pour vous dire ce
qu'on a fait pendant cette période comme
je le disais je vais les phillies
colisée les mesures de confinement ont
mis en lumière une traction numérique
plus personne ne peut ignorer
aujourd'hui et la fragilité des
personnes exclues du numérique donc sfr
a mis en oeuvre un plan d'urgence les
connectent et du ministère de la
jeunesse en équipant et connectant 75000
personnes exclues du numérique dont
cinquante mille élèves
très concrètement sfr a fait don de 75
il recharge prépayée invité les fans et
smartphones avec appels et sms illimités
et 750 mille giga de data pour que les
plus modestes puissent communiquer avec
leurs proches puissent continuer à
s'informer et puissent suivre leurs
cours à distance
l'autre grande mesure qui a été prise
parce que je vais pas je vais pas être
exhaustive sfr s'est engagé aux côtés du
secrétaire
chargé de la protection de l'enfance
adrien paquet afin d'équiper les
structures collectives de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance
l affaire a fait don de 500 box 4g
équipés de cartes sim ce qui a permis à
plus de 5000 enfants et adolescents de
suivre l'intégralité des cours dispensés
par visioconférence a fait de grandes
partenariat on a monté avec des airs
pendant cette crise pour permettre aux
personnes d'avoir accès au numérique
voilà en substance qu'on voulait vous
dire même si on a encore plein d'autres
choses à vous dire évidemment pour
rester pour rester concise et je
m'arrêterai là juste un mot de
conclusion pour vous dire 'est-ce qu'il
rejoint monsieur le président ce que
vous disiez en introduction c'est c'est
un constat c'est une conviction et c'est
une évidence pour nous parce que ça fait
des années qu'on travaille sur ce sujet
là mais c'est évidemment ensemble que
les entreprises des collectivités
locales l'état et les associations
doivent avancer pour offrir de nouvelles
de nouvelles possibilités du jeu du
numérique aussi bien aux français que au
territoire fait vraiment une
responsabilité globale et partagée parce
que je pense que je ne pouvais vous dire
avec juste merci et merci à toutes et à
tous de cette attention sont autant de
témoignages de la vivacité la diversité
des actions que vous entreprenez qui
vont de l'aide à l'équipement jusqu'à
l'accompagnement en informations
cependant à être avant que de laisser la
parole
notre rapporteur comme le veut à la
pratique je vous rappeler aussi que je
vous avais invité les uns et les autres
de mon propos liminaire à nous faire
part de la votre évaluation de la
pertinence de la stratégie nationale
pour u11 amérique inclusif et casey sion
à nous faire des propositions
je ne prends pas que beaucoup d'entre
vous peut-être me suis-je exprimé trop
du temps peut-être trop mal et peut être
aurons nous l'occasion de revenir sur
cet aspect j'avais mon vol vous avez la
parole
we re bonjour à toutes et à tous merci
monsieur le président d'abord je
voudrais aussi vous remercier et vous
féliciter pour tout ce que vous avez
déjà entrepris on découvre que vous avez
les uns les autres d'avoir pris
conscience et ensuite oeuvré déjà pour
lutter contre ce fléau
mais comme cela été rappelé par la
dernière interlocutrice mais l'inversé
je crois que on se rend compte que c'est
pas suffisant et de loin et puis que
nous devons peut-être mieux coordonner
toutes les actions que vous avez
entreprises mais surtout en développer
d'autres d'une vaine et c'est un petit
peu l'objet c'est même l'objet essentiel
de notre mission c'est de faire un état
des lieux de faire ce constat certes de
vous remercier pour tout ce que vous
faites mais aussi comme l'a rappelé le
président d'avoir un petit peu d'aller
un peu plus loin et d'avoir de votre
part des forces de proposition pour que
nous puissions essayé de contribuer à
l'élaboration d'une future politique de
lutte contre l'électronique mhz alors
moi j'ai noté que sur le sur le sur les
actions que vous avez menées
il est forcément aujourd'hui difficile
de savoir comment on peut déterminer
quels sont finalement les
responsabilités on est très conscient
que l'état a des responsabilités
importantes dans des domaines essentiels
comme la santé comme l'éducation
nationale comme tout ce qui peut
concerner la formation et puis ce
partenariat public-privé jeunes amiens
connaissez d'avoir des réflexions de
votre part pour savoir comment il
pourrait se construire
on a découvert au cours de ses auditions
que dans certains territoires
il y a des amorces de partenariat entre
le public et le privé
c'est le cas du sicoval c'est
l'intercommunalité importante de 100000
habitants côté toulouse que nous irons
certainement à voir donc comment comment
il imaginez-vous ce partenariat
indispensable
de toutes les forces que nous pouvons
rassembler autour de la lutte de ce
fléau est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
part de vos réflexions là dessus et
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous proposer
comme suggestion
merci qui veut commencer à répondre
il y en a que je vois à l'écran mais
d'autres que je ne vois pas je vois
comment percer brûle d'envié de
l'énergie
j'essaie de la parole alors dès que je
commence peut-être pour dire que ce
partenariat
ces partenariats public privé il existe
déjà et passait pas un mouvement
généralisé mais il existait là c'est ce
que je disais c'est à dire que nous sur
les territoires et sait faire on a des
délégations de service public
on a des partenariats autour de
l'inclusion numérique avec le
département donc c'est ça fonctionne de
plus en plus et on arrive à mettre plein
de choses en place ensemble on travaille
main dans la main le département des
pyrénées atlantiques
on a une délégation de service public on
travaille toutes les semaines ensemble
pour mettre en place des actions pour
l'inclusion numérique donc on a mis en
place ce pass numérique on a mis en
place un médiateur numérique sur le
territoire on met en place des
formations aussi numérique donc c'est
quelque chose qui existe de plus en plus
mais c'est vrai que ça c'est une
réflexion on se fait souvent avec julie
donc il est délégué général de la
fondation
c'est que en fait on arrive vraiment à
faire des choses très concrètes que
quand on travaille tous ensemble et on
dit tous ensemble c'est très large et
des collectivités locales mais c'est
aussi l'état quand nous on met un centre
emmaüs connect dans une ville on a
besoin de l'aide de tout le monde n'est
pas sfr ou emmaüs connect qui va dire ah
bah tiens je vais m'installer à toulouse
ça se passe pas comme ça passera avec
l'aide de la mairie toulouse ça se passe
avec l'aide des pôles emploi pôle emploi
qui oriente les demandeurs d'emploi vers
emmaüs connect pour les formes et donc
ça se fait avec tout un tout un
écosystème en fait ça existe déjà mais
tessa sans doute qu'il faut amplifier
c'est la fluidité en d'articulation
entre
l'entreprise entre l'associatif entre
les tares entre les voilà toutes les
structures publiques parce que en fait
on voit bien que c'est tout ça est
connecté qu'on arrive à faire quelque
chose sinon c'est théoriquement de 6 ans
il au bon bah c'est quand même mais à
moindre échelle
je sais pas si mes collègues ont fait
cette expérience là aussi sur à porter
est ce que vous entendez je vous en prie
a très bien pour vous êtes monsieur
monsieur de rivoire et safa public de
microsoft
vous me voyez maintenant je me permets
je suis ici vous remonter un petit peu
je suis tout temps aux intervenants
jouent aussi je me permets de revenir
sur les deux points que vous avez
soulevé le premier c'est que la
stratégie pour numérique inclusif
moi j'en retiens un élément extrêmement
intéressant qu'on a pris en compte lors
du développement de nos écoles ya c'est
l'inclusion des territoires et la
coordination entre le public et le privé
les associations dans les territoires
est effectivement comme le disait comme
disait ma collègue décès faire on a
beaucoup travaillé avec pôle emploi pour
que pôle emploi puissent nous refais
léché des demandeurs d'emploi qui
avaient besoin de ces formations
intelligence artificielle qui s'articule
sur 7 7 et 12 mois entérique en
formation théorique en alternance mais
c'est effectivement ce type de
coopération avec des agences publiques
et des associations comme simplon qui
peuvent permettre de de régler le
problème électronique mais je pense
qu'au vu de la crise actuelle
ce type de coopération va devenir de
plus en plus nécessaire donc tout toute
initiative tout processus tout
encouragement de ce type de ce type de
réunion des forces publiques privées
associatives
nous chez microsoft nous encourageons
vivement côté orange
avantage donc l'aspect territorial le
maillage à développer les ateliers
toutes les initiatives des uns et des
autres peut être à mieux coordonner en
commun et puis ce qu'on a tous dit elle
a besoin de soutien et de renforts sur
ce corps intermédiaires qui est le plus
à même en fait de communiquer et de
porter la plupart des sujets assez pas
toujours aux acteurs privés le faire on
a besoin du soutien des gouvernements
français soit 110 et 1500 bénéficiaires
de l'offre coup de pot ce qu'est une
offre très peu cher mais qui doit passer
par en france les commandes ploie ccc
vraiment domaine public que les
faisselles si vous voulez on a besoin
des pouvoirs publics poids pour ça et
puis la même manière que les autres
opérateurs
effectivement nous aussi et ce quelqu'un
en moselle dès lors qu'on a des
délégations de service public cet aspect
inclusion et parfaitement pris en sait
que j'ai sera ajouté
j'en vois effectivement que ce lien et
cet ancrage sur les territoires est très
important et moi je veux juste revenir
sur une sur un point c'est que je crois
qu'on va pas résoudre la voiture le
numérique parts égales par une question
de couverture mais vraiment pas une
question d'accompagnement occuperait des
bénéficiaires et je crois que là avec
nos mécénat de compétences et avec tous
les médiateurs numérique
on a un grand rôle à jouer et je crois
aussi qu'il faut encourager ces
initiatives des entreprises autour des
messages compétences vers nous on en a
200 sur tout le territoire
tu peux à se dépasser qui sont rappelons
le contact direct qui font vraiment du
qui privilégie le contact humain qui
alors là ça va être un petit peu modifié
mon gars comme ça et c'est vrai que la
notion d'accompagnement de formation
c'est vraiment essentiel dans cette
lutte contre l'illettrisme
et côté google je ne peux que me faire
l'écho de ce qui a déjà été dit par les
différentes structures je crois que les
collaborations entre le les partenaires
privés et publics sont déjà mises en
oeuvre
en tout cas nous lorsque l'on mène des
actions sur le territoire lorsque l'on
ouvre des ateliers numériques
on ne le fait jamais seul est long le
fais toujours main dans la main et de
concert avec les collectivités
concernées et on identifie les
structures pertinente pour le territoire
et on cherche à travailler avec ses
structures pour ne pas répéter ce
qu'elles font déjà mais pour apporter un
complément en collaborant avec elle donc
on travaille avec des structures
associatives économique institutionnel
des missions locales des agences pôle
emploi et je crois que effectivement il
faut il faut miser sur le lieux
collectifs pour tout ce qui est
inclusion numérique pour la stratégie
nationale
je sais pas si olivier tu veux tu peux
ajouter des éléments bien peu peut-être
un point sur le fait de ne pas oublier
façade ça a été dit de ne pas oublier de
l'icm ans se concentrer sur deux pavés
les jeunes générations plus tôt on voit
d'ailleurs dans nos ateliers numériques
on travaille avec des associations qui
vise les jeunes générations dont on a
parlé des des jeunes chercheurs d'emploi
des étudiants il ya aussi même avant ça
les jeunes générations qui vont pouvoir
être sensibilisés au numérique
et c'est dès ce moment là en fait qu'on
peut qu'on peut commencer à travailler
sur l'inclusion numérique mon travail
des associations comme ni enfance
génération numérique les petits
débrouillards qui vont donner aux
enfants les les premiers bons réflexes à
avoir par rapport au numérique est une
sorte de de littératie numérique qui est
indispensable pour pour la suite pour en
faire ensuite des utilisateurs avertis
couronne ou télécom on risque d'un
certaine unanimisme moi je dirais que
l'intelligence sur ces sujets là elle
est comme souvent dans les territoires
au fond on espère qu'elle est un peu
chez les opérateurs quand même mais elle
est quand même très puissamment chez des
gens qui sont au contact des personnes
qui ont besoin d'être d'être aidé
d'ailleurs on le voit bien puisqu'il ya
une multitude d'acteurs les missions
locales d'insertion qu'il faut jamais
oublier parce qu'elles font un travail
extraordinaire est une myriade
d'associations la france ne manque pas
si vous êtes à la recherche de gens qui
peuvent vous parler de ces sujets vous
conseille d'aller voir l'association et
mao à bastia qu'on a découvert récemment
et qui fait de l'insertion numérique en
partant de cours de musique alors leur
manière de travailler ces deux d'amener
les enfants éloignés du numérique à la
musique électronique et c'est comme ça
qu'il les a même ensuite à apprendre
qu'ils aient pris il ya une multitude de
démarches absolument remarquable et au
fond la grande le grand intérêt de la
stratégie nationale d'inclusion
numérique quand on tire un mot
rapidement que c'est précisément ce
n'est pas une stratégie nationale c'est
une stratégie pluri territoriales parce
qu'elle repose sur la scène de
labellisation d'action et qu'elle ne
cherche pas imposé par le haut et de
manière technocratique un système donc
non c'est à la fois sa force il peut
être un peu sa faiblesse
sa force parce qu'elle fait émerger des
initiatives intéressantes sa faiblesse
parce que on est en mal de cartographie
on est en mal d'identification de ces
associations
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est
assez preneur d'un peu de visibilité sur
ce qui a été labellisé sur ce qu'ils
avancent bien parce que nous on demande
que à aider qu'à apporter notre concours
mais c'est vrai que parfois on
farfouille un peu dans les territoires
de représentants locaux pour chercher
l'association qu'on pourrait venir venir
aider nous c'est vraiment une action
très positive et très intelligent qui
trafiquent m est ce que d'autres veulent
intervenir pour rester sur le sujet ou
répondre ou alors notre rapporteur
oui mais je suis président remercie
alors monsieur anthony colombani moi je
je remet en jeu
j'ai mis mon parole puisque en réalité
la question que je voulais vous poser
c'est est si vous aviez donc
une idée de l'échelle territoriale y
avez vous l'avez abordé à ce que vous
avez donc très bien résumé ce que vous
avez vécu certainement et moi je peux
vous dire que cette période de
confinement a évidemment révéler ce que
le numérique pouvait apporter en même
temps lorsqu'ils n'étaient pas
accessibles certaines personnes ce qui
est représenté comme handicap et de ce
fait la tente est encore plus importante
qu'auparavant dire que d'un seul coup
les territoires ruraux en particulier
ont découvert que finalement grâce au
numérique bien on pouvait entreprendre
comme ailleurs on pouvait réussir comme
ailleurs on peut habiter comme ailleurs
et donc la tente est encore plus
important et d'autre part je voulais
aussi vous rappeler que dans ces
territoires ruraux je crois qu'on a payé
le prix fort pour avoir une
infrastructure et vous savez ce que cela
représente comme investissement pour les
collectivités territoriales 40 50% du
coup tu si je prends le cas d'un
département va le que je suis élu 90
millions d'euros bien les collectivités
ont participé à hauteur de 50%
elles sont étriqués aujourd'hui par ses
participations et ce n'est pas la seule
celle du numérique dans par conséquent
je crois que c'est très important de
prendre conscience que l'accompagnement
maintenant ne peut pas être prise en
charge par cette collectivité qui ont
beaucoup de contribuer financièrement
pour obtenir tout comme désenclavement
un premier accord en numérique et de ce
fait aujourd'hui on est à la veille
puisque en particulier au sénat on a
beaucoup oeuvré pour que se mette en
place une agence nationale pour la
cohésion la cohésion des territoires qui
va ce qui est en train de se mettre en
place et qui va dessiner quelque sorte
donc une espèce de maillage territorial
ainsi qu'une stratégie trio thorel qui
va comme vous l'avez sous l'animent se
collant colombani éviter que nous impose
depuis paris et d'ici sont que des
associations que des acteurs de terrain
que que tous ceux qui se mobilisent pour
se doter d'un projet de territoire
peuvent intégrer
et donc c'est vrai que la question
il nous faut aussi déterminer grâce à
votre expérience c'est comment on évite
cette difficulté que vous pouvez voir
sur le territoire pour trouver les bons
interlocuteurs pour ne pas les avoir
tous ça c'est important
il faut tout de même réussi à les réunir
le chantier est tellement vaste qu'on ne
peut pas se priver d'une quelconque
énergie ou une quelconque de compétences
donc effectivement je partage comme vous
l'idée que nous devons travailler sur un
maillage territorial
peut-être par grandes régions puisque
les régions des compétences nouvelles et
importantes en matière de formation nous
avons d'énormes économies etc
et c'est ce que nous allons essayer de
bâtir avec vous comment peut-on définir
bon on va pas imposer partout les mêmes
modèles mais je crois que c'est
important qu'on définisse un maillage
territorial pour oeuvrer avec efficacité
merci j'ai une question de notre
collègue éric ott
merci président bonjour à tous moi
j'aimerais vous parler de l'ergonomie
des sites
on a souvent pour les personnes qui sont
éloignés qu'ils sont en fragilité
numérique ou est souvent des sites qui
sont actionnés anxiogène des sources de
difficultés supplémentaires
alors avez-vous des partenariats vous en
tant qu'opérateur avec les concepteurs
visant à améliorer l'accessibilité des
sites notamment des sites à vocation
administrative
on va vous êtes très actif pour
justement la catégorie des utilisateurs
mais je n'ai pas écouté de propos
concernant les concepteurs développeurs
qui sont aussi important dans la chaîne
pour vous en tant qu'opérateur merci qui
soit
intervenir pour la réponse
[Musique]
chez question qui embarrasse un peu j'ai
pas aimé
nous on a nos propres sites internet et
avec nos propres sites on essaye de
faire en sorte de les rendre plus
accessibles et simples parce que notre
objectif c'est quand même de vendre le
plus vite possible au plus grand nombre
en dépensant moins d'argent à une
certaine compétence mais j'allais dire
elle est interne après honnêtement
aujourd'hui il ya tout un tas de
développeurs en france et je pense que
ça peut passer aussi par le
développement de la belle il ya des
sites qui sont plus ou moins accessibles
il ya des savoir faire qui sont plus ou
moins développés notre collègue d'apple
évoqué tout à l'heure l'extraordinaire
fluidité des interfaces propre à cette
marque qui permet d'avancer très vite
sur ces sujets là et google n'était
évidemment pas du tout reste donc
peut-être beaucoup à faire en termes de
fluidité mais aujourd'hui des
compétences existent il faut simplement
que peut-être les acteurs administratifs
les collectivités les gestions de
portails administratif pour mener telle
ou telle démarche
les rendent un peu moins anxiogène et
une approche un peu plus clients évitent
des champs où il faut occuper cinq fois
avoir un mot de passe qu'on reçoit par
sms aurait inscrit ensuite sur le
portail bien ça tombe de guidelines en
termes de d'ergonomie qu'il serait bon
peut-être que l'administration
s'approprie et le sujet d'ailleurs
exactement le même pour les personnes en
situation de handicap parce que plus un
site est accessible et plus il sera
facile à utiliser pour les personnes en
situation de handicap mais je crois pas
qu autour de la table ou qu'on ait des
compétences techniques sur ces sites il
est là je réponds que pour apple par
rapport au site
il ya deux choses que vous entendez non
simplement déjà pour tout ce qui est
applications et tout ce qui les anime
sur l'app store les développeurs doivent
respecter un certain nombre de
guidelines et dans ces guidelines
il ya évidemment des questions de design
d'ergonomie d'utilisation de ceux ci est
donc tout cela allié avec ce que je vous
ai déjà exposé en termes d'accessibilité
sur nos produits rendent pour des
utilisateurs la navigation la
consultation des différents sites ou
applications le
la prise est possible en revanche pour
tout ce qui est si d'administration
relevant de l'état en règle générale
comme nous sommes associés à une
opération en lien avec le gouvernement
ou l'état d'administration règle
générale nous on travaille avec des
développeurs on le recommande des
développeurs de manière à ce que si cela
13 par l'app store ou même si c'est une
application via le web elles puissent
être design et de la manière la plus
facile facilitatrice pour l'expérience
visiter utilisateurs et donc en ce sens
nous on se fait fort à chaque fois
d'encourager justement parce qu' on
puisse prendre du quel que soit du que
ce soit côté entreprises au côté
administration le point de vue de
l'utilisateur
in fine et pour rendre l'accessibilité à
son site internet de la manière la plus
claire et les plus faciles à utiliser au
possible
donc en ce sens nous nous y sommes
vigilants après ça dépend plus aussi de
l'initiative de ceux qui vont créer le
sentiment est que de que de caunes y
penser mais on essaie de le faire en
tout cas nous à chaque fois que nous
sommes investies et quelques mots côté
google également au niveau de nos
ateliers numériques on propose très
régulièrement des sessions collectives
sur la création de sites à travers des
cas de les personnes peuvent poser
toutes leurs questions
elles ont aussi la possibilité de
prendre des rendez vous individuels et
justement on a très régulièrement des
questions sur l'ergonomie des sites
j'ajouterai à cela que l'on fait
intervenir des intervenants extérieurs
sur cette thématique là je pense
notamment une journée dédiée à
l'accessibilité qu'ont organisé
l'atelier numérique google de nancy en
juin dernier et était notamment
intervenus kobena avec une session sur
comment rendre mes supports numériques
accessibles
on ad'autres d'autres initiatives
dédiées aux développeurs d'applications
notamment
on a par exemple un outil qui s'appelle
accessibility scanner qui permet aux
développeurs d'identifier des pistes
d'amélioration pour améliorer
l'accessibilité de leurs applications
côté prix il ya deux dans la même la
même logique un fait nous on développe
toutes nos applications et nos produits
en interne m'entendais bien on a une
attention très particulière à tous qui
est l'accessibilité et comme je disais
logiciel est donc on met en place des
api et pour pouvoir rendre ça accessible
à tous les codeurs et on fait pas mal de
programmes de formation sur cette
thématique a également très bien merci
j'ai une voix quelqu'un touche aux
accords de pointe sur cette question
sinon j'ai une autre question d'une
collègue de notre collègue martin
berthet ci n'est d'après nos paroles
oui merci beaucoup résident bonjour à
toutes et à tous
vous l'avez dire je crois que c'est
madame versets de ses fers qui nous
disait tout à l'heure où effectivement
et électro nisme celle de la
responsabilité de tout le monde de
l'état des collectifs
dorian c'est un travail à faire et vous
l'avez très bien fait jusque là avec des
associations via vous vos fondations
[Musique]
j'aborde est-ce que je vais céder mais
j'entends qu'il ya de l'allant qui sait
que chez moi mais j'entends qu'il ya de
la friture sur la ligne effectivement
oui alors donc vous l'avez dire
qu'effectivement vous a mis beaucoup de
choses en oeuvre déjà depuis une dizaine
d'années c'est très bien on peut que
s'en féliciter
à présent les collectivités
territoriales c'est aussi de leur
ressort également l'état ont injecté des
dispositifs des moyens dans la lutte
contre l'électronique mais on ne doit
bien être des phoques justement 10 l
affaire de tous on le voit bien les
collectivités territoriales où l'état
est alors encore moins à présent que la
crise sanitaire est passée par là il n'y
aura plus suffisamment de moyens
injectés malheureusement comme en anjou
qui de toute la seconde est en fait les
premiers j'avais bien pas les premiers
mais être très intéressé par cette lutte
puisque si vous êtes une période vous
développer la fibre pour de meilleures
connexions un peu partout sur notre
territoire en lien avec les départements
et l'état vous développer la fibre mais
vous avez besoin bien sûr que derrière
relier les abonnés des personnes qui
répondent présents or ce n'est pas
encore suffisamment le cas malgré tous
les efforts tous vos efforts déployés
donc comment voyez vous le futur est ce
que vous savez en prévision de
multiplier ce que vous avez déjà fait
penser sur un même rythme de croisière
comment voyez vous le futur les uns les
autres en tant qu'opérateur pour
accentuer encore sept buts
merci merci
qui veut répondre en premier je peux et
désigné sinon c'est une question qui ne
trouvent pas de réponse mais chez colas
bas niveau je vois une question sur le
futur on peut parler on peut pas des
paillis ne pas y répondre
je laisserai ensuite la parole à
bérénice et qui va dire un peu plus mais
c'est clair que l'insertion numérique on
a souhaité en faire un axe assez forts
de notre de notre réflexion pas
tellement d'ailleurs pour gagner plus de
clients aujourd'hui mais mais plutôt
parce qu'on sent quand même un vrai
besoin de solidarité enfin quand à md
quand on interroge nos clients pour
savoir quelles actions solidaires qu'ils
aimeraient nous voir menés par exemple
ils nous disent que l'on doit s'engager
pour l'environnement pour tout un tas de
cause extrêmement noble on voit monter
quand même cette question de l'insertion
numérique donc oui c'est des choses sur
lesquelles on va travailler simplement
la difficulté on a évoqué tout à l'heure
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup d'action que
nous on peut pas faire seul
d'ailleurs aucun opérateur ne peut faire
seul sur sur un territoire donné
mais on a tout ce travail de
cartographie on est aujourd'hui en train
deux d'aller chercher les initiatives
les plus intéressantes
peut-être que quelque part c'est une
école du code peut-être qu'ailleurs
c'est une association qui va faire de la
formation pour lutte contre
l'illettrisme n'est pas seulement lié en
tout cas on a souhaité en faire en faire
un axe fort développement de notre
fondation
je rejoins ce que ce que dit anthony je
pense que en ce qui concerne le futur à
la tentation
notre vocation c'est de soutenir les
actions financièrement une fondation le
fait sur du moyen ou long terme on
souhaite continuer à soutenir des
actions déjà en place à soutenir de
nouvelles actions également et on a
vraiment besoin je pense de travail et
que les acteurs publics pour identifier
les meilleures solutions finalement sur
les territoires de soutenir
financièrement accompli moi je compte
intervenir courant si vous aussi vous
voulez c'est vrai que nous on a
effectivement commencé à lancer des
espaces de discussion avec nos
partenaires avec des associations avec
les missions locales qui nous qui nous
avec lesquels on travaille au quotidien
depuis des années pour voir
effectivement comment accélérer mais
aussi comment adapter nos voir ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui que cette fracture
numérique et ses effets sanitaires
elle a vu elle prend effectivement des
problématiques on n'avait pas
l'équipement c'est vrai qu'on veut pas
uniquement sonné et ça je pense que
c'est très important mais en même temps
on voit bien qu'ils allaient le plus
d'aidés publiques qui sont éloignés du
numérique mais aussi parce qu'ils n'ont
pas d'équipement alors que l'élection
c'est bien si on n'a pas d'équipement ça
sert à rien on va aussi aujourd'hui
renforcer nos appels à projets avec une
partie équipements une partie
accompagnement avec nos mécènes
compétences et nous nos milliers
d'heures numérique et c'est toute cette
offre globale que l'on va travailler
avec les associations et avec des
acteurs locaux
donc là c'est vraiment faim la
connaissons aujourd'hui le puits à moi
travaillent vraiment à ça à monter des
coups de discussion monter des groupes
de travail collectif participatif par
région et transverses la région avec
tous nos directeurs de programmes tous
nos délégués
un mécénat l'information dans les
régions et avec tous les acteurs locaux
et les associations qui aujourd'hui sont
quand même mise à mal
cette crise donc continuer dans ce
soutien mais vraiment adapté à adopter
notre façon de soutenir aujourd'hui et
je vous parle pas du monde de l'autisme
cela aussi on va devoir trouver des
façons d'accompagner différemment et sur
des os longs l'accompagnent depuis
longtemps mais dans des programmes très
structurant pour pouvoir accompagner
encore plus son os deviennent numériques
les importants et des personnes portant
un niqab
merci bien
j'ai une question de notre collègue
marie pier richer s'est lui bien
s'exprimer
paris pierre est ce que vous vous
entendez bien de mettre le son
merci donc je design remercier chacune
et chacun d'entre vous pour vos
interventions qui qui ont mis en lumière
les actions que vous portez j'avoue que
je ne pensais pas qu'il y avait autant
d'actions porté sur le territoire je
pense qu'il serait intéressant comme ça
a été dit qu'elles soient coordonnés et
qu il serait également intéressant pour
pour la mission d'avoir une cartographie
de vos actions pour savoir si elles se
se trouve sur les mêmes territoires
parce que il ya quand même des
territoires aujourd'hui entre guillemets
oublié on a parlé beaucoup de l'usaj il
ya aussi l'accès au numérique par les
réseaux et je pense qu'il serait
intéressant de voir si vous répondez aux
attentes sur les mêmes territoires et de
pointer les insuffisances qu'il peut y
avoir
moi je souhaiterais aussi mettre en
lumière quand même les actions des
collectivités territoriales je suis dans
la région centre val de loire dans le
département du cher et c'est avec des
fonds publics que nous avons que nous
déployons le numérique sur notre
territoire
et ça je tiens à souligner parce que
c'est un effort conséquent que font les
collectivités territoriales avec l'état
et pour moi l'électronique me commence à
la maison quand on ne peut pas accéder
au numérique et que l'on a des
difficultés pour la téléphonie il y a
des départements en france
moins de 50% je lisais tout à l'heure je
crois 38 38 % en lozère simplement
d'accès possible donc la fracture se
trouve se trouve là également ce qui
n'empêche que je suis sensible à ce que
à ce que vous développez pour pour
lutter contre lille etc trop nice merci
voilà est-ce qu'il ya d'autres questions
non moi je reviens une seconde sur ce
qui a été
me semble-t-il une des unes des éléments
forts de cette discussion c'est eux
ce partenariat que vous construisez sur
les territoires du mieux du mieux
possible et on sent que s'il y avait à
un cadre s'il y avait des références
s'il y avait un chef de file one
autorités compétentes pour mieux
organiser peut-être les choses
peut-être que dans ce cas la dure encore
plus d'efficacité pas si je me trompe
mais j'ai le sentiment que vous avez
rêvé sur un territoire avec très peu
d'informations sur ce territoire
territoire très peu d'accompagnement et
que vous êtes en quelque sorte livrés à
vous même et que peut-être s'il y avait
cette heure je ne dis pas que vous êtes
mal aussi un côté vous êtes attendus
mais s'il y avait une initiative en
réponse peut-être que les choses se
passeraient mieux est ce que est ce que
il ya là une réponse comme s'attendait
voulait des acteurs principaux du
numérique madame
oui merci de me donner la parole
effectivement je pense que vous soulevez
vous soulevez un point très important
très concrètement nous quand c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure mais quand
on veut installer un point emmaüs
connect parce qu'on identifie un endroit
où il ya un vrai besoin
c'est vrai que c'est emmaüs qui
l'identifient en lien avec nous mais
ensuite on doit se débrouiller pour
trouver les bons contacts pour trouver
le bon contact à la mairie parce que
souvent c'est la mairie qui va nous
mettre à disposition le local ensuite
aller voir au l'emploi pour leur dire
voilà on s'installe ici si vous pouvez
nous aider appelé chez les demandeurs
d'emploi vers l'antenne donc c'est vrai
que tout ça est assez compliqué et ce
serait beaucoup plus simple pour nous si
on avait un interlocuteur alors de temps
en temps ça arrive en exemple très
concret là là on est en train de penser
à l'ouverture d'un centre emmaüs
connecte à toulouse et est parti d'une
rencontre avec un député qui nous a dit
mais y'en a pas toulouse il ya un vrai
besoin
moi je vais vous aider et donc la lui il
nous ouvre les portes de des structures
publiques des collectivités locales et
c'est lui qui nous aident avec un c'est
lui qui fait le lien unique avec tout
l'écosystème et ça ça nous fait gagner
un temps un temps que la salle en fait
parce que c'est vrai que c'est c'est
très juste que vous dites c'est à dire
que sinon on y va à tâtons on finit par
y arriver mais on perd beaucoup de temps
permettez-moi encore de compléter pour
prolonger les réflexions de rapporteur
raymond vall de tout à l'heure je ne
sais pas s'il y a à gérer échelon
pertinent sur les territoires puisque la
france des tapis très diversifiée on
peut pas mettre le même costume
autrement dit pour chaque fois s'adapter
mais ce qu'il y aurait un ou plusieurs
périmètres qui serait en capacité de
satisfaire tous les territoires du quai
l'hexagone
alors là je parle pour les centres
emmaüs connect exclusivement m'étais
clairement à l'échelon municipal parce
que c'est là que ça se passe c'est la
mairie souvent qui nous trouve le local
c'est la mairie qui fait le lien pour
nous vers pôle emploi donc pour les
centres emmaüs connecte sur ce point
spécifique c'est vraiment la mairie
après c'est vrai qu'il ya d'autres
territoires par les délégations de
service public où là on a des
partenariats autour de l'impression
numérique
là c'est le département donc je pense
que faudrait presque faire une
cartographie et de ce qu'on met en place
et en fonction du besoin parce que je
pense que selon selon ce qui est bien en
place effectivement ça peut être la
mairie ça peut être le département ça
peut être ça peut être la région ça
dépend ce qu'on met en place en fait
tout à fait pour compléter ce que dit
que dicaire percée on a un bon exemple
c'est léo d'alcon en train de travailler
sur un programme pilote est donc là
c'est vraiment en lien avec avec le
département qui est un peu petit ami un
département qui est assez structuré il
ya vraiment un service et un département
lyrique dans tout le département dans le
cadre de ce programme pilote qu'on a on
a réfléchi à 3 donc savait que unis en
partenariat les critères sur l'oeil sur
le sujet on a rectifié 1 à 3 3 axes
majeurs le déploiement de la plateforme
pédagogique les banques site de la mise
en place de formations avec en
partenariat avec le département et pôle
emploi donc c'est à dire c'est pour
permettre à des personnes très éloignées
de l'emploi d'avoir les compétences
numériques de base pour être un tremplin
vers vers l'emploi et ensuite la ligne
ampl la mise en place donc avec mike
collecte d'un espace solidaire dont en
tout cas travailler avec des
associations ou des structures sociales
du département pour pouvoir permettre de
déployer l'offre leader et sait faire et
la connectique comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure en effet la première vraiment la
première étape pour la plus lutter
contre l'électronique mais députés et
ensuite d'être collectés enfin on
arrivera à l'accompagnement mais la
première étape celle et excitée d'être
collectés et donc c'est avec le
département là pour le coup mon travail
en été c'est vraiment en fonction en
fonction des territoires il ya des
fossés au niveau des sept plus tôt
n'était pas là et d'autres où c'est
plutôt au département si je veux
compléter quand on parle de territoires
ruraux nous on pense à nos tient lieu
solidaire donc on en a 23 en france dans
des lieux petites communes moins de
10000 habitants cd carrefour de
rencontres autour de numérique qui sont
vraiment construit en local alors avec
tout notre notre réseau à terre que ce
soit les directions les collectivités
locales mais aussi nos délégués
fondation des gens qui sont vraiment sur
le terrain
et puis les acteurs locaux se sont
l'amérique ce soit les associations les
propos vous avez l'offre la plus adaptée
que ce soit de la connexion de
l'équipement d'accompagnement pour les
publics éloignés pour les feignants
parce que pour le coup c'est ouvert à
tous le les habitants de ces communes
donc là c'est vraiment une problématique
locale et qui a ses spécificités bien
évidemment traiter au cas par cas dans
tour sur la base d'appels à projets
relâchement on revient c'est on n'a pas
en un cadre national solidaire mais
ensuite c'est vraiment un travail de
longue haleine aussi avec avec les les
institutions et les acteurs locaux
l'acteur est celui qui fait c'est
souvent quand même la commune ou
l'intercommunalité c'est vrai que là je
crois qu'on a tous eu ce sentiment
l'accès à ce niveau là que se font les
choses les plus pertinentes pour un
territoire donné
après certains départements se sont
saisis heureusement d'autres de la
compétence sociale
on a discuté par akalé aussi avec les
ars sur le sujet des gens hospitalisés
sur de longues durées qui peuvent avoir
aussi des problèmes d'accès numériques à
chaque acteur à chaque échelon
administratif de ce beau mille feuilles
administratif français il ya des
initiatives a fièrement remarquable mais
là où on est preneur peut-être d'un peu
de coordination au plan que d'être
cartographique juste identification
c'est sans doute au niveau régional
c'est sans doute là mayala cali vous
pourrez être concentré la formation de
ce qui se fait dans un territoire donné
et nous effectivement ça ça nous
aiderait au fil pour répondre par action
de la coordination entre acteurs privés
salée entre opérateurs quand on parle de
coordination entre nous on a toujours un
petit vent froid dans la nuque là parce
qu'on a des souvenirs assez désagréable
de l'époque on se parlait c'était pas
moi j'étais dans une autre vie
professionnelle j'ai et donc du coup
c'est les actions qui doivent quand même
resté un peu isolé alors ça nous empêche
pas de nous parler un peu a posteriori
pour éviter de laisser des territoires
complètement neutre de nos actions mais
c'est vrai que la coordination est
compliqué dans le cadre comme président
je peux terminer le jeu dont prix oui
donc petit à petit en fait il se dessine
le fait que les différentes initiatives
qui ont été prises récemment par exemple
l'initiative en matière de
réindustralisation à travers les
territoires d'industrie
le gouvernement a choisi de confier les
relais locaux aux préfets et aux
sous-préfets et le lait réunis autour de
la préfecture de région et aussi
régional bon on voit bien que ça c'est
une compétence chaux debry conomique
mais aussi et là je pense que par
rapport à ce qu'on a intégré dans la
définition de ce qu'on veut que la haine
c'est l agence nationale pour la
cohésion territoire face le préfet sur
un plan départemental peut-être le bon
maillot pour coordonner le public et le
privé puisque en fait
et la rs bien qu'aujourd'hui soit pas
clair mais je pense qu'on va y
travailler
très certainement mais les services de
l'état l'éducation nationale la santé
tout ceci le préfet devrait se voit
renforcée dans la gestion du relais
territoriale des compétences de l'état
donc côté les régions d'autres avec les
intercommunalités ont remis au goût du
jour la contractualisation dire que de
l'ensemble des epc lice il ya des
communautés de communes ou
d'agglomération contractualise avec la
région des compétences essentielles
comme la formation etc
donc c'est vrai que a priori on pourrait
alors bien sûr après les métropoles les
agglomérations c'est le sujet mais c'est
vrai que on peut se rechercher une
proposition qui tendrait pour faire
coopérer sur le terrain sur le terrain
le public le privé que le préfet et
sous-préfet joue un rôle essentiel
puisque ils le jouent déjà sur des
dispositifs importants qui touchent donc
à la santé à l'industrie aux services
publics
parce que on peut pas continuer à maillé
notre pays avec des maisons de service
public des tiers l'une des incubateurs
des espaces du télétravail et de voir à
nouveau on construit quelque chose en
même temps on a sur le plan scolaire des
lycées ou des collèges dans lesquels
forcément un espace qui pourrait être
utilisé dans tout ça il faut qu'on
arrive à les coordonner
et moi je pense qu'il faudra enfin il
faudra qu'on en discute de recel d'une
autre mission je pense que les préfets
les sous-préfets avec en face d'eux donc
les chambres consulaires
bien sûr les régions devront trouver
donc cette organisation de relais de
l'état sur le territoire que sont les
préfets même s'il est évidemment on peut
pas écarter le fait qu' il faudra mettre
un peu d'ordre entre les relations de la
rs et les préfets sur les territoires
parce que là franchement cette crise
nous a fait entrevoir des situations qui
n'étaient pas très très bonne voilà donc
moi ce que je vois je voulais vous
remercier d'avoir
donnez toutes ces informations vraiment
comme ma collègue agrément surpris de
tout ce que vous avez engagé déjà et
surtout de la volonté que vous avez
exprimées mais je pense que si le
partenariat avec le département pour
l'infrastructure est incontournable il
ya énormément de départements qui ont
joué ce relais et c'est grâce à eux
qu'un grand nombre de départements vont
être désenclavé sur le plan de
l'infrastructure
après malheureusement ils n'ont plus les
compétences pour suivre les autres
domaines c'est ainsi et je crois que
l'état de reprendre la même parce que il
s'agit quand même d'une responsabilité
aujourd'hui graves et sur laquelle la
volonté politique de s'exprimer
voilà vous avez pu suivre les échanges
de cette table ronde organisée hier avec
les opérateurs et sociétés du numérique
une table ronde organisée dans le cadre
de la mission d'information sur la lutte
contre l'illettrisme et inclusion
numérique
je vous remercie notre attention je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les émissions et tous les
articles de la rédaction sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr je souhaite une
excellente journée à tous